fighters do have curbs in their life
it's an up and down peaks and valleys
but when they've grown up for ten years
you feel it you don't want to see the
valley
unless that icy Rockies rally big-time
and it was a it was short-sighted on my
part I thought okay this is dramatic but
wrong you know it's dramatically right
but philosophically wrong to the
audience it's safe to say that most
people really don't like Rocky five even
Sylvester Stallone himself has gone on
record to express his disappointment
with the film behind the scenes turmoil
in an overwhelmingly negative audience
reaction led to by far the most disliked
movie in the franchise it nearly even
cailed the entire series being the last
Rocky movie for 16 years before Rocky
Balboa was released in 2006 to redeem
the saga in the eyes of many we could
spend plenty of time going on about what
went into the making of this film and
what led to certain unpopular decisions
being made there's a lot of information
out there about what was supposed to
happen in Rocky 5 Rocky was supposed to
die the direction of the movie was
supposed to be very different
etc but this video isn't about how Rocky
five went off the rails it's about
making it more appealing to the audience
while retaining most of the original
intent hindsight being 20/20 we can use
elements from the preceding films in the
series to make it more compelling and
all-around more satisfying story like
Rocky's comeback in Rocky Balboa
or the introduction of Adonis Creed from
the more recent Creed films the latter
being the most intriguing notion along
with other important elements to
retroactively Lee fixed this fourth
sequel what if Adonis Creed was in Rocky
5 this is fan scription
before we get into anything know that
this is a sequel to my previous fan
scription about rocky 4 titled what if
Apollo Creed didn't die in rocky 4 so
I'd suggest checking that out if you
haven't the bottom line is that Apollo
survive despite with Ivan Drago and the
injury sustained paralyzed him from the
waist down thus in this version of rocky
5 Apollo is still around and will have a
big role to play in the story now let's
dive in
the opening of Rocky v recapping the
Drago fight from the end of four has
always been my favorite of all the
intros bill Conti returned to score this
film and his contribution to this
sequence was phenomenal it's one of his
best fight overtures combining older
themes with new more intense and
powerful stuff everything feels so much
more impactful and chaotic the return to
this classic approach was also a
welcomed one the synth soundtrack in
rocky 4 was always something that bugged
me this in combination with some really
well done editing captured how truly
brutal that fight was I wouldn't change
a thing about it the next scene with
rocky in the shower calling for Adrian
snaps us back to reality rocky 4 was so
far outside what we had come to expect
from the series up to that point that at
times it felt like a borderline fantasy
seeing the physical toll drag those
punches had on rocky is exactly what we
needed this is a scary scene rocky is
quivering disoriented and confused we
have to keep this tone going early in
the movie so this is where our changes
start instead of wiping - Rocky's
triumphant return to the us at the
airport we dissolve to the doctor's
office scene from later in the film a
specialists explained that Rocky's
initial tests don't look good but aren't
quite clear yet you will have to go
through more to see how serious his
injuries are Adrian takes this as proof
enough and after seeing his physical and
mental state following the Drago fight
she's looking for any reason to stop her
husband from fighting Rocky's reaction
to the suggestion is similar to what
happened in the film not in here office
while he was feeling his age before the
Drago fight rocky doesn't want this to
be the end it's not how he wanted to go
out
Adrian pleads with him that he can't
keep doing this to himself and his
family reluctantly rocky agrees to
finally hang up his gloves we cut to
five years later yes we're actually
going to have a time jump here it's
desperately needed so the year is 1990
and we fade in on a news report about
rocky it's sort of a where are they now
piece talking about Rocky's financial
troubles and then he's having an estate
sale today this is another thing that
people generally
don't like about Rocky five but it has
to happen for there to be an interesting
enough narrative to warrant another film
at the beginning of rocky 4 he was on
top of the world
he lived in a mansion bought robots and
all types of extravagant things for his
family with his loved ones close by and
all his fancy possessions there's not
much of a conflict to threaten the
character that's one of the things I
really appreciated about Rocky 5 it
tried its best to bring the series back
to basics dropping rocky back into his
old surroundings was a good way to do
that and remember I'm trying to stick to
some of the original intent here
rocky 5 can't work without Rocky losing
his fortune and dragging him back to a
place where he can pull himself out of
as for that overly complicated
explanation the piece of faithful Foley
had you signed wasn't a request for an
extension on your tax returns it was a
blanket power of attorney in favor of
the accountant who was involved in some
very high-priced commercial real estate
we really don't need all that this is
where the time jump can work in our
favor the news report can quickly
explain as is laid out in the film that
rocky failed to pay his taxes and
mortgage in several years we know rocky
is terrible with money and if he trusted
someone who wasn't fully on the
up-and-up it's not hard to believe that
most of his fortune would be burned
through in a few years with no new cash
coming in rocky overspends gives copious
amounts to charity and wasn't even paid
for his fight with Drago in 1985 with
rocky being a little more punchy post
drago he's not comfortable doing any
kind of commercial work and soon after
his retirement he was out of the public
eye anyway all he really wanted was to
just live a sort of secluded life with
his family losing everything he gained
over his career is as sad as it's
portrayed in the film we cut to the
estate sale and this is our introduction
to sage the loans version of Rocky's son
Robert we keep their interaction here
which is very sweet and sets the
relationship up well don't worry about
it we've been down before
I'll get it all back we just gotta stick
together
geez all right you know Mick used to sit
fighting over till you heard the Bell we
for the next couple scenes nothing
changes rocky and Adrian reminisce on
the origin of the relationship rocky
goes back to the old neighborhood and
find himself caught up in old bad habits
this leads to one of the best scenes in
all the rocky films which is the
flashback sequence at Mick's gym I love
that moment and it was a stroke of
genius to bring burgess Meredith back in
that capacity his mere presence just
adds something that was truly missed
from there this scene stays the same
showing a distraught rocky moved back
into the old neighborhood with his
family he later accompanies Robert to
school trying to teach him about his new
surroundings so the relationship still
has some focus early on from here things
take a much different turn one of the
biggest changes I'm going to make
regards Tommy Gunn a lot of people
really don't like that character but
we're gonna use him in a different
capacity in this version Tommy Gunn is
sort of in the Union cane role when we
first see him he's going to have already
been with the promoter George Washington
Duke for a good while he's fighting in a
championship bout and wins the title
easily making him the youngest
heavyweight champion ever this is quite
the accomplishment but the crowd is not
thrilled we can use part of Mason Dixon
storyline from Rocky Balboa here the
heavyweight division is as bad as it's
ever been not to mention with Duke in
control some of these fights aren't
exactly 100% legitimate it's been half a
decade since rocky retired and people
long for the days when they had someone
like him to believe in this leads us to
the post fight press conference which
plays out in a similar fashion to the
original film the reporters give Tommy a
hard time for the fight looking so easy
which draws Dugan to half-heartedly
defend the new champion one of the
reporters brings up that Rocky is
reopening Mickey's gym and that maybe
Tommy should go train with a real
champion the press room erupts at the
suggestion
there's only one bellboy
now bellboy was a true people's champion
but in times
tommy-gun tommy is still the hothead we
see towards the end of the original
version and he's human about not being
respected Duke chases him away from the
podium and they engage in a slightly
altered version of that same hallway
scene
Tommy storms off leaving Duke with his
business partner Merlin Duke seemed
struck with an idea Gold rocky out of
retirement for a match with Tommy Merlyn
says Rocky's been out of the game for
years why would he come out of
retirement now Duke smirks and simply
says none of these bones things straight
polynesia book we cut to a familiar face
Apollo Creed front and center is cutting
a ribbon at the opening of a Children's
Hospital he's been doing a lot of these
charity type events in the years since
the Drago fight paralyzed him he's
rededicated his life to giving back also
his reputation and public image have
never been better while he's still the
confident former champion we know and
love it's obvious that Apollo is changed
for the better with his wife Marianne at
his side
Apollo takes a few questions from a news
crew covering the event after a query
about the hospital the reporter asks
Apollo's thoughts on infamous promoter
George Washington Duke calling Rocky
Balboa to come out of retirement for a
fight against the reigning heavyweight
champion Tommy Gunn Apollo is a bit
taken aback by the question and says
this is the first time he's heard about
in his usual charismatic way he makes a
light-hearted joke about letting us old
dinosaurs finally go extinct they all
chuckle at his quip but under his smile
Apollo seems a little bothered by the
question outside Mickey's gym Duke
approaches rocky and that scene plays
out as in the film with a couple small
differences this is the first time rocky
meets Duke as he tries his hardest to
pitch rocky the matchup with Tommy
Duke is nothing if not a devilishly good
motivator what he says in that scene
about rocky still being a draw and how
one fight could fix his financial
situation are all valid statements rocky
is quickly drawn into Dukes charismatic
promise of redemption you represent the
dreams of the longshots the little
people that never wills identify with
you identification is the key to public
success you're a true champion a true
product or people don't sell it
saladboy they're still buyers they're
gonna last ever you say you a fighter
then fight Adrian gets involved and
chases Duke away but Rocky is left
frustrated and somewhat intrigued by
Dukes offer meanwhile Robert is having
the same tough problems adjusting to his
new school which means he still gets
beat up and robbed of his jacket when he
goes to the gym to tell his dad about
what happened he sees him working with
the boxers Robert can sense how worn-out
and mentally drained Rocky is so he
reluctantly goes home to let his dad be
with no Tommy Gunn to compete for
Rocky's affection in this version Robert
sees his father constantly working to
try and regain some respect for his
family Rocky's demeanor is very
off-putting to his son and he
becomes unapproachable to Robert the
relationship slowly begins to strain
Duke continues to hound the Balboa's
calling them making statements to the
press etc but for the most part his
approach is to flatter rocky with his
legacy and sell him on delusions of
grandeur when he realizes this isn't
working
Duke decides to switch strategies he
sees a newspaper article about Apollo at
another charity event he stares at it
for a moment we cut to another press
conference with Duke and Tommy where
Duke says he had rocky all wrong he's
not the pure underdog champion he
thought he was interested from earlier
Apollo is seen intently watching the
press conference at his home at Mick's
gym one of the fighters directs Rocky's
attention to the nearby TV set that's
tuned into the press conference as well
Duke first calls rocky an irresponsible
coward then pulls out a file of papers
and exposes Balboa's criminal record to
the press it's been alluded to several
times before and even specifically
mentioned in Rocky 5 with the
investigation of the account out pops a
criminal record of Rocky's for assault
in connection with loan shark the public
wasn't aware of Rocky's transgressions
prior to this and it would absolutely
taint his image a bit his mostly
squeaky-clean persona could be in some
jeopardy but that's not the biggest
announcement Duke has here
he says scumbags stick together and
starts talking about how other past
champions aren't quite as authentic as
they appear to be namely Rocky's old
friend
Apollo creep he asks would a true
champion hell decent human being father
an illegitimate son and leave him and
his mother for dead because that ladies
and gentlemen is exactly what our old
favorite Apollo Creed has done the man
has a son who he's never met who's all
alone at a foster care facility right
now because the boy's mother just
recently passed away
see now I understand why someone like
Rocky Balboa wouldn't want to fight a
real champion like Tommy Gunn here there
are just too many skeletons in the
closet Tommy Gunn would not only
humiliate and expose the bum as a far
inferior fighter but he would also
expose him as they deplorable disgusting
degenerate that he is only in America
can someone be lifted to the
stratosphere only to be hiding who he
truly was
all along apollo is silently confused
and shocked at this statement he hears a
plate break behind him and turns to see
Marianne with a devastated look on her
face at mix all the fighters are looking
at Rocky
he's clearly embarrassed and asks one of
them to shut off the TV
[Music]
we dissolve to the foster care facility
where Apollo's son named Adonis by his
late mother is staying
Apollo is seen waiting with one of his
handlers and is wheeled into the room
where his supposed son is a caretaker
there tells him Adonis has been isolated
from the other kids because of violent
outbursts as soon as he catches Adonis's
young eyes
Apollo sees something familiar he
delicately tries to talk to his
four-year-old son and does his best to
hide his own shame and sympathy for the
boy after a few words are exchanged
Adonis asks Apollo who he is Apollo
can't bring himself to answer as he
holds in a tear from falling down his
cheek this scene is meant to be somewhat
similar in tone to Adonis's first
meeting with Maryann in the first Creed
film Adonis is introduced to the
audience and with this discovery
Apollo's character continues to evolve
the scene where Robert knocks out the
bully to get his jacket back stays the
same he's been training to defend
himself at mix with Jimmy and Paul II
while Rocky's been distracted with work
he goes straight to the gym proud of his
accomplishment and eager to show his
death with all it's been going on
recently
rocky seems genuinely uplifted to see
his son so happy however they only have
a brief exchange before Jimmy interrupts
to say that rocky has a visitor rocky
says it could wait but Jimmy thinks
he'll probably want to see this guy now
rocky reluctantly tells his son they can
talk more at home
Robert is left feeling neglected again
and leaves the gym just closed for the
day so rocky walks to the other side of
the empty space and sees Apollo waiting
for him
rocky seems to have been expecting this
but he finds it's not so easy to look
his old friend in the eye
Apollo comments about rocky not
returning his calls for a long time
Balboa says things have been pretty
rough for a while now Apollo asks if he
needed some help with money why didn't
he just come to him rocky says he could
never ask that of him and blames himself
for his family situation Apollo accepts
that and shifts the conversation to
what's been said in the press lately
they talk about how Duke has damaged
both their reputations rocky can't help
but ask if the claim about his son is
true Apollo says he went to see the kid
recently and that yes he's the father
but swears he had no idea he had a
moment of weakness in the months leading
up to the Drago fight but he promises
that was a lifetime ago he's a different
man now who's still paying for the
mistakes of his past
his wife is taking some time to herself
and he's going to be taking the kid in
rocky asks his name and Apollo responds
adonis rocky lightheartedly jokes that
that sounds about right and the tension
is broken for a moment
Apollo asks rocky if he's thinking about
taking up Dukes challenge to shut him
and his boy up for good but Balboa does
not seem interested
Apollo doesn't know about Rocky's
possible brain damage so he says he's a
little surprised but understands he can
tell rocky is very distant so in an
attempt to reach him Apollo mentions
that he still has nightmares not about
the fight with Drago or almost dying but
that he often dreams about simply
walking running playing with his kids
those are the good parts the nightmare
starts when he wakes up and remembers he
can't do those things anymore and all of
it is his own fault he has to live with
that if he still had his health there's
nothing he wouldn't do to help his
family old or new the retired Italian
stallion silently soaks in what's been
said
Apollo tells rocky he'll see him around
and to try to return a phone call every
once in a while rocky is left conflicted
and pondering Apollo's words that night
rocky and Paulie go to Andes where Duke
and Tommy show up it's meant as another
publicity stunt but this time tempers
flare
what a bummer what do you work there huh
are you knock them down won't you try
knocking me down no no no in the ring in
the ring Tommy Gunn only fights in the
ring rocky is ready to fight Tommy then
and there but in this version duke and
his crew pulled Tommy away and they
leave before rocky can get to it's clear
from the look on his face that Balboa
has had it with this game they've been
playing we fade to a courtroom setting
where rocky sits in front of the
Pennsylvania Athletic Commission he's
there alone and as the sequence proceeds
it's clear that he has reapplied for a
boxing license the scene plays out
almost beat for beat as it did in Rocky
Balboa the Medical Advisory Board has
informed us that the battery of tests to
which you've been subjected you've
passed these tests with flying colors
the tests rocky took this time around
were further advanced from the one he
took after the Drago fight he also never
had any more done after that as was
suggested so any damage done wasn't as
bad as the first scan showed however the
board does not want to grant rocky a
license due to his age he'd probably be
about 44 or 45 at this point an elevated
risk for possible brain injury it's here
where we get one of Rocky's famous
speeches you shouldn't be asking people
to come down here and pay the freight on
something they paid it still ain't good
enough gummy you think that's right I
mean maybe you're doing your job of why
you gotta stop me from doing mine the
board seems moved by the former champ
statement as he walks out of the
courtroom it's Christmas Eve at the
Balboa home and Robert is there with his
new friends from the neighborhood
rocky pulls Adrian aside to tell her he
heard back from the Athletic Commission
and he was approved for the boxing
license Adrian wasn't aware that rocky
reapplied until after he did so she's
been upset about it since rocky told her
a few days prior to this
thus Adrian isn't thrilled with Rocky's
news and walks away from him Robert
overhears that his dad might be fighting
again and eventually snaps at rocky all
his frustrations about being ignored for
so long boil over and now that his dad
might be fighting again he'll see him
even less do you remember last June when
we had fun we had a good time last year
and you ain't the same either
Rocky and Robert have a tense argument
in the basement this scene in the
original film is actually pretty good so
I wouldn't change much about it our same
basic idea is still getting across you
don't have no time for nobody so I got
no time for you the other person you
said I would be number one you said that
you lied you lied to me and you lied to
mom
Rocky chases his son outside but he runs
away with his friends Rocky has been so
caught up with trying to get some
respect back for his family that he
hasn't realized Robert has desperately
needed his father all his frustrations
with Duke his son and his current
situation combined he and Adrian get
into an emotional shouting match in the
street about everything that's been
going on I want this good for the family
I don't want this I don't want this come
back to you and get my brains beat up
first but these guys say hey Adrian
quickly changes focus to Robert and
rocky not taking into account how he's
been feeling since moving back to the
old neighborhood is lost he needs you
you're losing us rocky you're losing
your family
rocky apologizes for blowing up at her
adrian tells him that if fighting one
more time is something he feels he has
to do and it's safe then do it but he
has to fix things with Robert first that
scene on the corner with Robert
reconciling with his dad is a favorite
moment of mine there's no need to change
a thing here except the mentions of
tommy gun I know I made a few mistakes
you know
I swear to god it's just gonna become
waste the tension in their relationship
was always something I liked in Rocky
five that angle was new to the series
and I think it mostly worked even if a
lot of the movies surrounding it did not
home team
yeah home team
from here we get a scene like the one in
Rocky Balboa where Rocky's fight team is
back as they build a strategy to take on
Tommy Gunn
Robert Apollo Tony and Paulie are all
there Apollo has been handling the
business end of things and his Co
promoting the fight a conditioned Duke
had to except for rocky to agree to the
match
so that means Duke is making way less
money than he thought he was going to on
this fight a small come up it's for the
character at this point but we need this
fight to happen in the ring to do that
we need Duke to partially get his way
however he's fuming about the
arrangement and needs Tommy to win to
keep exploiting the young champion if
Tommy loses all his value is gone which
means Duke will have to start from the
bottom up with someone new the main idea
here is that Duke is doing everything he
can to make sure Tommy wins this fight
rocky and especially Apollo's
reputations have taken a hit in the
public eye but they're still very
popular and Rocky's return has almost
erased Dukes attempt to defame him this
fight is officially for the title but
it's obviously much more personal to
rocky and Apollo rocky can not only get
some measure of revenge on Tommy and
Duke but he's looking to restore his
name earn enough money to get his family
out of the woods and make his son proud
of his father again there's a lot on the
line here
Tony realizes that rocky knows
everything there is to know about boxing
at this point but he's five years older
and five years slower than the last time
he stepped into the ring he's going to
have to call upon all his tricks he's
learned over his career to have a chance
against Tommy who was less than half his
age and in his prime the focus they're
aiming for with Rocky's training is good
old fashioned blunt-force trauma
horsepower heavy-duty cast and
pile-driving punches that will have to
hurt so much they'll rattle his
ancestors with everyone behind him Rocky
is confident in what he has left in the
tank there is no lack of motivation as
he's as determined as he's ever been
make no mistake about it the Italian
stallion has something to prove
yeah let's start building some hurtin
bombs rocky is training hard with his
son close by getting to watch his dad
like in the old days and they bond over
this period
finally backstage the night of the fight
Apollo and rocky have one more
conversation it's reminiscent of the one
they had in Rocky 3 the old rivals
turned friends admit there's a lot on
the line for both of them and Apollo
feels like he's vicariously living
through Rocky Balboa jokes that he knows
they both said this at least a dozen
times before but this really is it win
or lose
rocky retires for good following this
fight Apollo agrees and thanks him for
letting him be a part of the show one
more time
the last line Apollo says calls back to
better days the fight is of course at
the Philadelphia spectrum the place
where Rocky's mainstream career started
and the perfect place for it to end and
a funny twist rocky chooses to wear the
shorts he was advertised wearing and his
banner in the first fight with Apollo
that being the reverse of what he
actually wore red shorts with a white
stripe he makes his entrance with his
team at his side even Robert is allowed
to be ringside
Adrian sits in the crowd as usual
looking proud but nervous she can't help
but be reminded of the image of rocky
shaking after the Drago fight
nonetheless she does her best to be
supportive rocky is overwhelmingly
cheered as he's the underdog once again
he's gotten himself into great shape
which surprises even the commentators
Tommy's introduced with Duke at his side
he looks all business and as angry as
we've seen him thus far with Duke so
close by you can cut the tension with a
knife there are a lot of bad feelings
going around and this fight isn't gonna
be your standard title bout as the fight
starts Tommy establishes his power
advantage and his youth serves him well
against his much older opponent we're
gonna say Tommy is like a more
methodical clubber lang type with a lot
more stamina he wins the early rounds
with Rocky getting in a few good shots
towards the middle of the fight rocky
takes the advantage by winning a few
rounds unconventionally he switches
styles a few times to throw Tommy off
using the speed Apollo taught him in
short bursts to win a few battles rocky
knows he can't match Tommy's youth so he
uses
a few tricks in combination with his
usual straight on approach as we go into
the later rounds Rocky's starting to not
look so hot the fight becomes a brawl
that feels very personal with malice
behind every hook rocky dishes out as
much as he's absorbing but Tommy can
take a punch almost as well as Balboa
finally in the eleventh round Rocky is
hit with a shot that knocks him straight
to the ground
everyone cringes at the connection I'm
Rocky seems totally out of it Adrian and
Robert can barely look at the carnage as
the referee counts Rocky's head is
spinning just as it seemed it's all over
rocky here's a familiar old voice
[Music]
Duke and Tommy are already celebrating
when rocky makes it up at the count of
nine
he seems we energize dat somehow Tommy
is flabbergasted that Rocky is still
conscious but goes in to finish the job
rocky surprises him with a few hard
shots before the bell rings and being
round 11 in his corner
among deafening rocky chants he looks
out at age she seems worried but Braves
threw with a nod to her husband Robert
asks if he's alright bloody and bruised
rocky smiles at him and says the road
will move rocky looks back to see Apollo
who's holding up his fist and his show
of unity rocky does the same the bell
rings for the 12th and final round
both men are exhausted and it's all
about who wants it most hard shots are
landed by Tommy and rocky it's back and
forth for the whole round Duke is
screaming instructions at the champion
[Music]
Tommy has rocky in the corner and it
looks like he has him trapped
after a few more exhausted blows rocky
ducks and pushes Tommy into the corner
with one final shot he lands his
signature left hook as the bell rings
ending the fight the crowd erupts
humming wasn't completely knocked down
by the shot but he almost stumbles over
on the way back to his corner rocky is
embraced by his team and family Adrian
comes ringside next to Robert
Tommy's team is confident he won the
fight as Duke proclaims loudly the
official scorecards are in and the
announcer declares they have a split
decision one judge has it for each
fighter before the third judges call in
a twist on the original film in the
franchise rocky ends up winning the
decision and the championship the crowd
and rocky sides celebrate while Tommy
throws a tantrum and leaves the ring
Duke is incensed and can't believe what
he just heard Rocky has handed the title
as he hugs his wife and son he promises
no more and thanks them for letting him
do this one more time
Duke however isn't finished with the
Balboa's and approaches the family
[Music]
touch me now sue
mom bug touch me nos Robert throws a
quick right hand into Duke stomach he
didn't see it coming and is doubled over
by the strike rocky a surprised but
responds with Zoomer for what Duke still
hurting turns around and says his famous
line with Duke gone rocky continues to
celebrate with everyone as gonna fly now
plays in the background we dissolve to
the rocky statue where rocky and his son
are running up the steps we get that
same ending scene with Rocky and Robert
as the father gives his son Mickey's
cuff link except this time Apollo rolls
up in his wheelchair with young Adonis
and Tony at his side he makes a comment
about rocky being late and they all
lightheartedly head towards the art
museum doors we're left lingering on the
statue as the measure of a man song
begins and we're treated to images of
all the previous Rocky movies as the
credits roll and that's it my version of
rocky 5 to be honest there's a lot I
still really like about this movie it
had a lot of potential but that
potential was buried in bad early 90s
music and an unsatisfying plot I did my
best to keep the essentials that the
film gave us and build on the story
about family while cutting out the
fallen pupil Tommy Gunn stuff also
having a parallel side plot with
Apollo's discovery of Adonis was
important to the story
Apollo is still dealing with what
happened to him at the hands of Drago
adding Adonis in there would challenge
his new outlook on life but I think
Apollo would rise to the occasion now
that I've covered Rocky's 4 and 5 where
do I go from here with this story well
nowhere with this version of Rocky 5
there's no need for a Rocky Balboa movie
to redeem the franchise and we took a
lot of elements from it anyway honestly
we could just jump to the first Creed
movie from here it takes place 25 years
after rocky 5 so in that time both
Adrian and Apollo could have passed away
rocky could have lost touch with the
Creed's and things would play out in
just about the same way I think here is
a good place to stop but I do have more
to say about Rocky 5 so make sure you
tune in to the fan scription podcast
where Rob Walker and I discussed my
rewrite and what our thoughts are on the
original movie check the description
below for a link and subscribe to us on
iTunes be on the lookout for more
episodes of fan scription coming soon
thank you guys so much for watching and
remember keep punching
[Music]
you